OUTFRONT tonight, but two
Russian military giants dead tonight,
one of them
the most senior general to die in Ukraine
since the war began.
Lieutenant General Oleg
so got killed in a strike
on a Russian military base in Berdiansk
This is according to a telegram channel.
A Russian one
soldier was a rising star inside
Putin's military.
Back in 2021
picked to speak at a cadet ceremony
that was attended by Putin himself.
And tonight, it's not just him.
The mystery is growing over
why another top Russian
military figure was murdered.
And this in broad daylight.
This is a submarine commander
shot multiple times
while jogging inside Russia.
And the details about his murder.
I mean, it's unbelievable.
According to Russian state media,
the killer was able to monitor
Stanislav Osiecki Every is every move.
They were tracking his run on the popular
running app Strava
so they could see exactly
where he was at every second.
And according to reports,
the gunman was waiting in a park
where there were no cameras.
And when risky,
a former submarine commander passed by,
he was taken out.
We've got some new video in tonight.
Of the raid
to capture the alleged gunman
after the attack.
According to state media,
he was found with a pistol
and a silencer.
But adding to the mystery of this
right being shot
multiple times,
a gunshot while on a jog in Russia.
The news of the former commander's
death actually
came from
the Ukrainian Defense
Intelligence Agency.
In an unusually detailed statement,
the agency said, quote,
The submarine was jogging
in the 30th
anniversary of Victory Park in Krasnodar
around 6 a.m..
He was shot
seven times with a mackerel pistol
as a result of the gunshot wounds.
Eric Ski died on the spot.
Now, despite such detail,
no claim of responsibility
yet from anyone.
And it all comes on
the same day that Ukraine
and the United States are at odds.
In fact,
the biggest rift
between the two countries
since the war began
Ukraine desperately
wants an invitation
now to join Naito after the war
as president, Zelensky told us.
But President Biden,
along with allies,
has refused to do that.
Zelensky tonight
calling the decision, quote,
unprecedented and absurd,
even as messages
supporting Ukraine's bid to join
Naito are on windows of shuttle busses.
Carrying people to
and from the NATO's summit.
It's the core of the entire summit.
The words are simple. Why?
While you were waiting for the bus,
Ukraine is waiting
to become a NATO member.
We have a lot to get to tonight.
A lot of these stories rapidly
developing through the day.
So let's begin in Kiev
with Alex Marquardt and Alex.
A tense day between Ukraine and Naito.
What can you tell us about
how today's summit went
It was
Erin Zelinsky made clear
going into the summit
that he wasn't going for fun.
As he said,
he wanted a concrete timeline of how
and when Ukraine
would be invited to join NATO.
Now, it is clear
that Ukraine is not going
to be getting that invitation
anytime soon.
Instead, the NATO's alliance
telling Ukraine telling
Zelensky that they will be invited
when allies agree
and when conditions are met.
Right now, Erin,
the allies do not agree
and it's not clear
what those conditions are
Ukraine's president
taking the stage today
at the NATO's summit,
thanking flag-waving, Lithuanians
for their support, saying
Ukraine's flag is still alive and free.
Not only the Ukrainians,
but special
naito will give Ukraine security.
President Vladimir Zelensky said Ukraine,
not zero,
not Syria in eastern
Ukraine will make NATO's stronger.
But as the Lynskey mingled tonight
with Naito leaders,
his country's future and Naito
remains uncertain,
simmering underneath his deep frustration
over the lack of urgency and clarity
to join the alliance.
It's unprecedented and absurd
when time frame is not set.
Neither for the invitation
nor for Ukraine's membership,
he tweeted today.
It seems there is no readiness
neither to invite Ukraine to naito
nor to make it a member of the alliance.
NATO's secretary
general stated
clearly that Ukraine will join NATO's,
but in the future, quote,
when conditions are met.
And if you look at all
the membership processes, there are
been time
lines for those processes.
They are conditions
based has always
been the first condition for the U.S.
to war with Russia needs to end
before an invitation can be made.
And Zelinsky
made clear to OUTFRONT
in a recent interview
that isn't soon enough.
Invitation just technical think
just wording.
Invitation Ukraine to need to
not down the line now.
Now it's very important.
It will push Russia out
as the NATO's summit opened.
Russia sent a wave
of almost 30 attack drones towards Kiev
and the critical port city of Odessa
Air defenses managed to shoot down
most of them and no one was killed.
But buildings were severely damaged.
Ukraine firing missiles
deep behind the front lines
hitting the Ukrainian held
city of Verdansk in the south.
Plumes of black smoke rising nearby.
Yet another Russian general, Oleg
Sokoloff, was killed
with a long range rocket,
according to Ukrainian officials.
And a Russian telegram channel.
General Sokolov would be the most senior
Russian general to be killed in Ukraine
so far
and would deprive Russia
of one of its most experienced generals.
And while the list of mysterious attacks
inside Russia grows
a one time
submarine commander, Stanislav
Shinseki, was murdered while out
running in southern Russia.
His regular jogs
recorded on the Strava app
and his route,
according to a Russian media outlet,
was tracked by the killer
and Erin Brzezinski was
the deputy commander
for mobilization
for the Crash Center City.
That is according to the Russian
investigative committee,
which, as you noted, says
that a man is now in custody.
He was found with a pistol,
with a silencer,
which is presumably the murder weapon.
Ukraine has not claimed responsibility
in any way, though.
It is really interesting,
that statement
from the Russian military
intelligence agency.
It really surprising amount of detail.
And then when it comes to Lieutenant
General Todt, sort of he was killed
reportedly, according to both
a Ukrainian MP
and that Russian telegram
channel by the storm shadow
cruise missile
that was offered to Ukraine by the Brits.
It is the longest range missile
that Ukraine has in its arsenal.
Verdansk is well behind the front line
on the Sea of Azov.
This general
becoming the latest
in a long line of Russian generals
killed during this Ukrainian campaign.
Erin.
All right, Alex, thank you very much.